hey guys I'm Adam Lambert and I am here
today to talk about my first times boo
my first kiss my first kiss was on the
beach with a girl named BJ it was just
kissing no BJ's first embarrassing
moment on stage oh there's been plenty I
did remember a time when I was
performing with Queen where I jumped
down to the audience to kind of like
sing to some of the fans that were there
and then I walked back up onto stage and
I step back up and I had to reach up
really high with my leg as the stage was
high and it ripped the back of my pants
wide open and the audience just watched
it happen my butt was hanging out I had
underwear on it was uh that was
embarrassing
of course I laughed about it I mean it
was funny no one wants to pants ripping
open my first red carpet experience I
think the first time I walked a red
carpet was when I was in a musical
called hair the musical in Germany and
we had like a big opening night yeah it
was the first time I had done that and
if there was press there and it felt
very official I remember being like yeah
like this first CD I ever bought I think
I bought two CDs at the same time I
bought Mariah Carey emotions and I
bought Wilson Phillips I remember the
name of the album but those were my
first two I think
couldn't be more different first time
getting starstruck I think the first
time I got starstruck is I did a musical
years ago in Los Angeles of the 10
commandments and the lead who's playing
Moses was Val Kilmer and of course I had
seen him in Batman and Top Gun guy was
like he's a movie star this is crazy
first celebrity crush mmm I think
Leonardo DiCaprio in Romeo and Juliet
the Baz Luhrmann movie I thought he was
pretty cute I then very quickly got my
hair cut just like him I had that like
parted in the middle step like step cut
from the 90s you know which is coming
back in style apparently which is so
ironic and yeah I've been seeing it a
lot of like a lot more and more first
memory of American Idol the first
audition my first audition when I was
doing the show that season was it was at
a place called the Cow Palace which was
big arena and we had to line up outside
at like 7:00 in the morning and wait and
wait and wait to come in one by one it
was a really slow line and thence we got
in there was like a ton of people in
there and we had to sit and wait in the
bleachers for about five or six hours
before we got to go up and sing it's a
long day one day my first job I worked
at Starbucks I was in school at the time
so I could only work the weekends I had
to open the store so I was up at like
5:00 a.m. as a teenager on the weekend
when you're in high school that is the
last thing you want to be doing so I was
like I don't know about this but I would
get in there and drink like you know
thirty cups of coffee within the first
thirty minutes so I was pretty lit first
time meeting Queen was on the finale of
American Idol about ten years ago I had
sung Bohemian Rhapsody as my audition
song for competing on the show and they
had seen it apparently and they were
invited on to the finale to perform and
it was surreal and honestly there was so
much going on and it was so busy that I
don't think the weight of that moment
hit me until a week later I remember
just thinking wow I sung with Queen it's
crazy and if somebody had told me hey
guess what in ten years from now you're
gonna be all around the world with Queen
singing lead vocals with them I would
have thought nah just full of it so I I
think maybe like fate came in and and
and and played a hand in that moment
thank God I picked that song please
check out my brand new EP it's called
velvet side a lead singles called super
power it's out now just happened
you